[Music]
last year I said four
shots but this year we going
eight Mis understanding like on the way
y
shoot um it's amazing but it's not a
coincidence seven is the number of
completion three time 7 is 21 here we
are um we here for it guys get in the
back can we close that door
[Laughter]
please we just came wait y'all being
serious I'm being
[Music]
[Applause]
serious all right now go I got to answer
this you had a failed repeat in college
um going for the second title in 2018 so
I mean what was that on your
mind Emily was that on your mind coming
into this at all and does this sort of
feel like a Redemption moment for you in
that way I I can't hear Emily cuz she
straight dissed me just now who voted
Asia fourth place for
MVP on it step forward come on Now's the
Time for the real slip Shady please
stand up come on come on where you at
Own It Cassandra please go with your
question we not worried about that I
just want to know the people want to
know we just
[Music]
PE Galler get it
together you been raising your hand Come
on talk to
[Music]
us Spanish right now because a lot of
people in Spanish is watching you right
now back to back CHS you already know
what it is
[Music]
B